you lived in a haunted house oh gosh yes
I did did you really I did all of a
sudden just things started to the the
the dishwasher would start to go or the
coffee maker would start to go or the
stereo would just turn on at full volume
and it was terrifying I had this someone
come over to my house and they do so
they had frankincense and they put it in
a little dish and sort of start saying
all these things in the first Corner
that she went to the dish cracked
thick thick 1975 ashtray that was
sitting on the table and that cracked
and she asked me to leave then I I lost
you to leave yes because she had to have
a little talking to with what did the
ghosts I was terrified he hated my
roommate
hey take it for what it is I'll send you
all the stuff did you tell the roommate
no I moved out you moved out